[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
fabien roussel bonjour fabien docet
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
député du nord et secrétaire national du
parti communiste
on commence donc avec cette phrase de
christophe castaner c'était hier au
sénat il faut faire en sorte que chaque
photo chaque accès chaque mot y compris
des expressions racistes fasse l'objet
d'une enquête d'une décision d'une
sanction et je suis sur ce sujet
intransigeant vis-à-vis des policiers
qu'il faudrait qu est ce que vous pensez
de cette phrase il a raison ce sont les
bons mots enfin enfin mais il faudrait
que ce soient suivies d'actes parce que
des violences qui ont été constatés de
la part de policiers à l'encontre de
citoyens français
il y en a il y en a eu beaucoup
notamment pendant les manifestations de
ces derniers mois avant la pandémie avec
les gilet jaune et donc il serait bien
que tout tous ces actes qui ont été
constatés qui ont dit qu'il ferait
l'objet de poursuites fasse réellement
l'objet de poursuites et donc il faut
aller jusqu'au bout
effectivement et il faut qu'il y ait une
justice y compris quand ce sont des
policiers qui ont commis des erreurs des
actes ou des propos racistes injurieux
soit lourdement condamné chaque citoyen
chaque homme chaque femme de notre pays
doivent avoir les mêmes droits et je
ressens chez des jeunes le un sentiment
d'être stigmatisés
surtout quand on est de couleur
différente
ils subissent ddd contrôle policier
répété plusieurs fois par jour compte
c'est dans les transports parisiens
notamment dans dans certains
arrondissements
ce n'est pas à crier dans l'absolu n'est
pas juste je pense que là la hiérarchie
policière
les supérieurs hiérarchiques doivent
donner des instructions qu'ils fassent
en sorte que la police soit plus juste
et dans ses contrôles ce qu'elle ne fait
pas aujourd'hui je ne dis pas que la
police raciste parce que je sais aussi
que chez les policiers
il y en a beaucoup qui souhaitent
exercer leurs missions correctement la
cgt police ça existe
elle n'est pas raciste mais il ya plein
d'autres gendarmes policiers qui ne le
sont pas mais il suffit que certes il
suffit que des supérieurs hiérarchiques
lâche la bride en leur disant allez y
lâchez vous et il peut y avoir
effectivement des policiers qui se
privent pas là par contre d'excès de
zèle qu'il faut condamner puisque vous
parlez des supérieurs hiérarchiques le
patron de la police nationale s'exprime
ce matin dans les colonnes du parisien
il dit la police n'est pas raciste nous
sommes un exutoire facile écoutez il ya
un exemple concret c'est la faire dans
ma traoré ça fait quatre ans que ça dure
ce jeune homme a été fait l'objet d'un
plaquage ventrale
il a dit j'étouffe il en est mort
l'enquète n'est toujours pas aller au
bout il vient d'avoir une expertise qui
disent que c'est pas ça qui a provoqué
la mort ce qui suscite la colère de la
famille que l'on peut comprendre et
c'est pour ça que les paroles du premier
ministre elles sont belles mais il faut
rendre justice véritablement et c'est
cette injustice là qui crée de la colère
parce que il ya un sentiment d'impunité
quand des actes et là pour le coup avec
ce jeune homme un jeune homme qui est
mort qui était sportive qui était en
pleine jeunesse et et à cause de ce
plaquage ventrale qui doit être
interdite dans notre pays comme aux
etats-unis c'est cette méthode
d'arrestations qui provoque l'asphyxié
l'étouffement et bien à cause de ce
plaquage entre à lille en est mort il
faut nous demandons à ce que cette forme
d'arrestation de plaquages ventrale soit
interdit notre pays dans notre pays
c'est la même cause qui a provoqué la
mort de ce jeune homme en scooter qui
avait été arrêtée plaqués et qui en est
mort c'est ce n'est pas acceptable dans
notre pays
le pays des droits de l'homme justement
une manifestation de soutien
adama traoré a eu lieu mardi soir et
contre les violences policières est ce
que dans la forme vous soutenez cette
manifestation qui a rassemblé vingt
mille personnes dans un contexte d' état
d'urgence sanitaire
écoutez j'ai été moi-même aussi à la
manifestation des salariés de renault
maubeuge et on était dix mille voilà
donc si aujourd'hui donc c'est notre
problème de tels rassemblements dans ce
contexte non ah non non c'est d'ailleurs
je commence à en avoir marre de cet état
d'urgence qui imposerait aux français de
rester chez eux et de nous interdire de
manifester de qu'on a le droit d'aller
travailler à l'usiné on a le droit de
faire tourner l'économie de notre pays
et il faut le faire je le conteste pas
mais par contre manifester non on doit
subir des plans sociaux
on doit subir on nous demande de baisser
nos salaires on nous demande d'accepter
de faire des sacrifices mais manifester
surtout pas rester chez vous alors ça
non quand la colère elle est là et quand
elle est justifiée elle doit s'exprimer
que ce soit pour défendre les droits
d'un jeune qui est qui est mort et dont
la famille réclame justice où que ce
soit pour défendre son travail sa
dignité
et bien cette ses revendications la
doivent s'exprimer
les aplats deux mêmes formations pour
ses côtes mais bien sûr comme nous le
faisons pour réclamer la gratuité des
masques pour tous sauf un il ya
aujourd'hui dans notre polaire dans
notre pays une colère justifiée du fait
que nous les français ont le sentiment
de payer cette crise pour laquelle ils
ne sont pas responsables mais c'est eux
le monde du travail les salariés la
genèse qui devrait payer le coût de
cette crise basta c'est fini quant à y
aller quand on va chercher l'argent là
où il est
mais pas dans nos poches sur cette
manifestation contre les violences
policières bruno retailleau qui le
président du groupe l'est républicain
sénat a dit hier que certains cherchent
à utiliser le drame des états unis pour
leur tournée contre la république qu'est
ce que vous en dites
le drame aux états unis soulève des
questions importantes sur les droits de
chaque citoyen qui doivent être les
mêmes quel que soit leur confession
religieuse leurs convictions politiques
ou leur couleur de peau et aux états
unis on sait bien que cette question
elle se pose depuis des dizaines
d'années voire des siècles depuis la fin
de l'est de l'esclavagé
et cette question elle est toujours
posée et avec force
c'est ce pays qui a fait élire barack
obama on a vu comment derrière les
forces d'extrême droite se sont
réveillés aux états unis et c'est
aujourd'hui un président il s'excuse
passe en france et ce parallèle qui est
fait aujourd'hui un président d'extrême
droite un fou furieux soutenu par marine
le pen qui dirige et qui en appelle à
l'armée pour qui traite de terroristes
ces hommes et ces femmes américains
blancs et noirs qui manifestent ensemble
pour réclamer justice
le parallèle avec la france eh bien il
peut se retrouver chez ces jeunes ces
familles qui réclament justice pour
adama traoré parce qu'ils ont ce
sentiment d'injustice mais je ne fais
pas le parallèle parce que nous n'avons
pas la même histoire dans notre pays
et je ne considère pas que notre que la
france que le que nous avons un état
raciste je ne fais pas ce parallèle on
vous dira la laisse que néanmoins vous
craignez un embrasement notamment due à
cette colère sociale et sur ce sujet
particulièrement des violences
policières
est ce que vous craignez de ce que ça
peut donner ces manifestations à force
le le le il peut y avoir un sentiment il
peut y avoir un sentiment est plus qu un
sentiment une envie de de se révolter
pour exiger le respect des droits de
chaque citoyen d'un autre pays quand je
dis que c'est pas la même histoire c'est
que en france la révolution de 1789 a
déclaré les mêmes droits pour tous les
citoyens d'où qu'ils viennent
nous sommes très attachés à la défense
de ses droits la france est reconnu pour
ça mais c'est en recul
cette déclaration est en recul on le
voit bien et donc il faut les faire
respecter je ne souhaite pas à ce qu' il
y un embrasement de colère et de
violence est donc le meilleur mais ce
que vous leur donnez donc le meilleur
moyen c'est d'y répondre et c'est de
faire en sorte que les jeunes de notre
pays et les mêmes droits et que la
couleur de la peau ne soit pas ne
fassent pas l'objet de discriminations
que ce soit al embauche au travail où
que ce soit dans les contrôles policiers
or ça ça existe dans notre pays c'est
une réalité
un jeune aujourd'hui
qui n'est pas blanc a beaucoup plus de
difficultés à trouver de travail qu'un
autre mais tous les jeunes souffrent
aujourd'hui d'une précarité accrue et
d'un taux de chômage élevé donc il faut
répondre à cette crise de la jeunesse
qui demande à pouvoir être respecté et
vivre dignement et justement on va
parler de ces questions d'emploi de ces
questions sociales on va accueillir
pascal jalabert qui représente la presse
quotidienne régionale bonjour pascal
vous représentez les journaux du groupe
ebra les journaux régionaux de l'est de
la france on va parler sociale fabien
roussel puisque emmanuel macron edouard
philippe rencontrent aujourd'hui les
partenaires sociaux pour parler d'emploi
des annonces sont attendues qu'est ce
que vous attendez com annonce
aujourd'hui le sentiment des français du
monde du travail et c'est de se dire ils
vont nous faire payer la crise on va
nous demander encore des efforts et des
sacrifices et vous entendez bien les
ministres qu'ils disent ou des chefs
d'entreprise ou le medef qui demande à
donner des jours de congés à accepter de
gagner moins à travailler plus et
effectivement c'est au monde du travail
que l'on va demander des efforts ou de
payer la facture de cette crise ce n'est
pas acceptable s'il y avait fort à faire
l'effort doit être partagé et tout le
monde doit contribuer à hauteur de ses
revenus mais aujourd'hui on fait porter
l'effort essentiellement sur le monde du
travail
on ne va pas les chercher dans le
capital dans les grandes fortunes
les moyens de se relever de cette crise
et celle à l'injustice et les inégalités
qui peuvent être créés dans notre pays
pour vous les salariés ne doivent pas
être obligés de travailler plus accepté
de baisser leur salaire pour faire face
à cette crise pendant une période donnée
mais on peut pas demander à ce que le
capital justement exige moins de
rendement on ne peut pas demander à ce
que les fonds d'investissement qui ont
prêté à 12% à conforama à camaïeu l'état
qui prête lui aussi à 12% dans les
entreprises en difficulté je parle avant
la crise parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus
le cas mais tous ces prélats qui ont été
données on peut pas demander à ce que
c'est tous les prêts qui ne sont pas à
0% justement tous ces prêts à 12% peut
pas demander est-ce qu'ils soient
annulées vous rendez compte combien ça
pèse sur une entreprise quand il y à des
fonds d'investissement qui réclament des
taux d'intérêt de plus de 10% ce sont
des taux usuriers
c'est une pratique dans notre pays et
donc c'est fo réclament 10 20 30
millions d'euros par an de paiement en
taux d'intérêt c'est autant d'argent qui
va pas dans les salaires dans les
investissements dans l'outil de
production et après on demande aux
salariés d'accepter de de ne pas avoir
de hausse de salaire ou de travailler
plus mais enfin ça va bien c'est
toujours le monde du travail qui paye et
jamais le capital il faut inverser la
ram et pourquoi on ne rétablit pas la
peau de solidarité sur la fortune
pourquoi on ne rétablit pas une taxe sur
les dividendes pour empêcher encore ces
entreprises il y en a aujourd'hui plus
de 60 dans les cent vingt plus grosses
capitalisations qui vont verser 40 entre
les gares de dividences et les coudes en
fin mai allons chercher l'argent là où
il est et pas à chaque fois dans la
poche des français
un mot il ya une idée de gérald darmanin
qui est de relancer la participation que
les salariés des actionnaires de leur
entreprise et perçoivent une part sur
les bénéfices qu'elles réalisaient ce
que ça c'est une bonne idée mais enfin
gérald darmanin il a qu'à dire ça ou
salariés de renault à qui on va leur
dire que c'est fini
4600 emplois supprimés arnaud 3009 chez
camaïeu 8000 à conforama
elle est où la participation chez ceux
qui perdent leur emploi lui il parle
d'entreprises qui doivent réaliser des
dividendes pour mieux les partager
mais à quel prix des entreprises
réalisent des dividendes aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui des entreprises qui
réalisent des dividendes le font au nom
de critères de performance de
compétitivité qui demande aux salariés
d'accepter de travailler plus avec des
salaires moindres
alors bien sûr ça dégage des dividendes
et donc vous aurez le droit en retour à
quelques miettes
m'enfin quand bien même ils auraient ils
auraient de miettes au lieu d'une
ils doivent pour cela accepter beaucoup
de sacrifices les hommes et les femmes
de ce pays les les travailleurs ceux qui
ceux qui déjà ont des travaux pénibles
ce sont toutes ont été en première ligne
dans nos hôpitaux quand ils sont dans la
fonction publique hospitalière ou dans
la fonction publique
ce sont eux qui étaient en première
ligne les éboueurs les caissières les
soignants et caetera et donc on va leur
dire on va partager les bénéfices
enfin et sylvie vous cela il faut qu'ils
redescendent sur terre quand même sur
renault justement je vais vous prendre
l'exemple de vaud
gan en allemagne qui a remis ses
salariés sur les chaînes trois semaines
avant la france et qui au bout de quinze
jours leur a dit désolé on vous remet au
chômage partiel parce qu'il ya des
voitures partout sur les parkings qui ne
se vendent pas en france il est
aujourd'hui 350 milles renault sur des
parkings qui attendent des clients dont
certains ne se vendront pas comment
peut-on garder des salariés dans ces
conditions là puisque les voitures ne se
vendent pas et peut-être ne se vendront
pas ils vont pas produire peu pour rien
non mais vous avez bien qu'aujourd'hui
dès que l'on sera sorti de cette période
confinement et on y sort là de plus en
plus la consommation la reprise de
l'activité va redémarrer et les primes à
la casse ou à la reconversion qui ont
été été annoncée par le président de la
république sont un premier signal qui
peut inciter à déstocker finale mais
c'est une mesure qui peut y contribuer
nous avons d'ailleurs je vais pas
contester cette mesure
ce que je regrette c'est que le
président de la république quand il
prête 4000 5 milliards à renault ne
conditionne pas ce prêt à la
relocalisation des voitures produites
aujourd'hui en turquie en roumanie ou en
slovénie et je ne demande pas de fermer
ses usines là et pénaliser les ouvriers
turcs roumains ou slovène
je demande juste à ce que l'on produise
en france les dacia les clients ou les
twingo fabriqués dans ces pays mais
produit chez nous ça représente 300
mille véhicules que les français
achètent mais qui sont produits là bas
pourquoi on est les produits pas dans
nos usines à nous pour vendre ici et les
français il ce qu'ils accepteraient bien
de payer 100 ou 200 euros de plus parce
que ce serait produit en france mais ça
créerait des milliers d'emplois
donc quand on accorde quand l'état quand
5 milliards d'euros à une entreprise
comme renault dans laquelle en plus
l'état est actionnaire
il doit dire ok 5 milliards mais vous
relocaliser ici trois cent mille
véhicules produits là bas et vous
investissez dans des citadines des
voitures pas chères populaire que les
français achètent beaucoup plus que la
talisman ou déçu à 30
milou 70000 euros c'est ça l'erreur
stratégique de renault c'est d'avoir
gardé en france les gros véhicules
polluants entre nous et les petites
citadines pas cher à l'extérieur parce
que la marge était faible
et ben moi je préfère un rôle d'un
groupe renault qui fait une faible marge
mais qui maintient ses emplois ici je
préfère des salariés au travail plutôt
qu'au chômage on voit fabien roussel les
chiffres sont vertigineux chiffres de la
récession chiffres de la dette chiffres
du déficit comment on relance l'économie
qu'on doit avoir lieu le plan de relance
et qu'est-ce qui doit contenir pour vous
un plan de relance aujourd'hui c'est de
dire si on avait un petit peu d'ambition
dans ce pays
il n'y aura pas de hausse du chômage
il n'y aura pas de hausse de la pauvreté
dans notre pays
nous sommes un pays riche qui a des
compétences de l'intelligence encore une
capacité industrielle que justement doit
restaurer et foot pour faire face à tous
ces défis qui sont devant nous sociaux
écologiques le besoin de services
publics les réponses à nos concitoyens
nous allons engager un vaste plan
d'embauché dans notre pays pour répondre
à tous nos besoins et quitte à ce que
notre pays s'endette et ils s'endettent
lourdement aujourd'hui lancé par l'état
que cette hand est que cet endettement
servent l'économie réelle contribuer à
créer des emplois
que ce soit dans notre industrie pour la
redresser une industrie qui respecte les
êtres humains les hommes et les femmes
qui travaillent dans les usines comme
les réseaux des ressources naturelles
donc il faut avoir une industrie du 21e
siècle et en même temps un état qui
donne des moyens à nos services publics
pour faire face aux besoins de notre
pays notamment en matière de santé où il
ya ces cent mille embauches au moins
dans les hôpitaux d'après les syndicats
et autant dans les ehpad d'accord pareil
pour l'éducation nationale comment on va
continuer à enseigner avec sans
embaucher massivement dans nos écoles et
faire en sorte que l'école soit
obligatoire et pas sur les la base du
volontariat
les besoins sont immenses je vous parle
pas de la dépendance de s'occuper de nos
personnes âgées ou de la petite enfance
en matière de services vallée de la lys
besoins sont il m'a parlé de la santé
puisque vous étiez hier à l'hôpital
de creil quel message vous ont fait
passer les soignants est ce que le
secteur de la santé va dans le bon sens
d'abord les soignants me disent vous
ségur la santé on n'y croit pas ce
gouvernement nous a menti
on a dû faire face à la crise tout seul
les ars c'est bidon pendant trois
semaines les trois premières semaines me
distillant puis j'en ai pas fait qu'un
d'hôpital les députés communistes ont
entre eux font la tournée des hôpitaux
depuis un an
députés et sénateurs ils disent on le
croit plus gouvernement pendant trois
semaines on nous a dit que les masques
chirurgicaux ça servait à rien la totale
donc aujourd'hui ce qu'ils disent on
veut des hausses de salaires on veut pas
qu'on nous donne des congés ou une
médaille
on veut des hausses des salaires 20% de
hausse de salaire on veut des bras ils
veulent des moyens humains
il valait plus nombreux au cas où il ya
une nouvelle pandémie au cas où il ya
une nouvelle vague
on ne veut plus subir ce que nous avons
subi et on veut une médecine de
proximité
on veut des hôpitaux de proximité on
veut ré ouvrir des maternités des
services d'urgence des services de
réanimation
là où on en a fermé à la campagne en
zone rurale mais aussi dans les grandes
villes dans les grandes zones urbaines
regarder la seine-saint-denis comment
elle a souffert et puis en outre-mer qui
à part que la métropole l'outre-mer a
payé un lourd tribut à cette crise parce
qu'ils sont sous dotée en matière de
service public c'est inadmissible c'est
pas ça la république la république c'est
les sites les mêmes droits pour tous nos
citoyens sur tous les territoires
c'est ce qu'on disait au début c'est
valable pour la santé oui alors haussé
que dernier on parlait beaucoup du
communisme municipal parti communiste
gérer beaucoup de villes
et puis ben depuis l'aube de ce siècle
c'est plus compliqué on a vu des grandes
villes tarn nîmes le havre 7 abandonné
le parti communiste la le deuxième tour
est très difficiles dans beaucoup de vos
fief en seine saint denis saint denis à
gardanne dans d'autres villes dans le
nord
comment vous expliquez que ça
n'imprimait plus et qu'à chaque élection
municipale c'est plus difficile pour le
parti communiste
moi j'ai jamais parlé de communisme
municipal
c'est une expression c'est votre
expression je sais mais je sais que le
parti communiste français a une
implantation locale forte
d'ailleurs le premier tour des élections
municipales a montré que nous étions
la troisième force politique en nombre
d'élus locaux dans les villes et les
villages de notre pays parce que
quelqu'un peut lui conseiller municipal
a élu dès le premier tour une aide parce
que nous avons beaucoup d'hommes et de
femmes au parti communiste dévoué pour
leurs populations qui sont très présents
pour dans le bénévolat pour pour mener
des combats pour des services publics
pour défendre la poste pour voilà pour
aider les gens dans leurs difficultés
pour pour défendre le social comme comme
j'entends pour défendre la ruralité
nous sommes reconnus pour ça nous avons
été de ceux aussi dans les grandes
villes qui avons mené des combats pour
la culture
l'accès pour tous aux sports pour la
jeunesse et nous avons mis en place les
maisons de l'est mais je sais que c'est
donc c'est notre histoire mais c'est
aussi notre avenir c'est combat là nous
continuons de les mener et donc je sais
c'est ce deuxième tour des élections
municipales donc va clore cette séquence
je pense que parti communiste français
restera avec encore beaucoup d'élus qui
ont le sens de la république et qui ont
mis au coeur de leur combat la défense
de la commune et des citoyens aient les
mêmes droits pour tous pour tous les
citoyens
un mot sur une ville le havre 1 pas
d'accord trouvé entre les communistes et
les écologistes est ce que vous ne voit
pas la porte à la victoire des leurs
philippe alors c'est pas ce que c'est
pas ça qui s'est passé c'est que la
liste conduite par jean paul lecoq est
une liste citoyenne à laquelle participe
le parti communiste français et les a
soumis et la discussion qu'ils ont eue
au sein de cette liste a été de préférer
de choisir c'est surtout les citoyens
qui ont exprimé ce souhait de maintenir
au second tour la même liste qu'au
premier dans un souci de cohérence
il appelle cette liste appelle les
forces de gauche le parti socialiste
les écologistes moi-même à venir les
soutenir dans leur campagne en
respectant leur choix de rester la même
liste qu'au premier tour pour préserver
leur cohérence et d'appeler et dont ils
nous appellent à venir les soutenir au
second tour face à edouard philippe qui
lui laisserait la victoire avec la crise
et la peine
passe partout ailleurs il c'est l'appel
que je lance à mes collègues
julien bayou olivier faure jean luc
mélenchon et d'autre je pense qu'il sera
important que nous soyons tous ensemble
réunis au havre pour montrer que cette
ville a un avenir qui ne passe pas par
la république je vous irez faire surtout
quand on a un premier ministre qui dit
quand je suis triste mais je ne
souhaitais une campagne commune dans la
vidéo soit jeudi je vais la mettre
mais je le saurai guy forget merci
beaucoup merci c'est à dire celle
d'avoir été avec nous